- How long you been doing
stand up now, James?
- Man like about 10 years.
- 10 years? How old are you?
- I am early 30's.
(laughter)
- What are you pregnant?
- Hey, I heh.
(laughter)
- I'm early 30's, it's not
what you think, don't judge me.
- 'Cause listen if they're
doing some high school movie
and they need the dumb dude,
who still can't graduate,
- Yeah.
- I want to be that dude.
- This guy here.
(laughter)
- Yeah.
- You never want
to let the age out.
- Nah. Nah.
- Where you from?
- I'm from Los Angeles,
South Central adjacent.
- Wow.
- Yeah.
- 'Cause if I say South
Central, you're gonna think
of your favorite scene from
Boys in the Hood or Baby Boy.
And I grew up where they
kept the craft services.
- Okay, okay.
- You know what I'm
saying, two blocks away
from the scene is
where I was growing up.
- I got it, but
you could see it.
You could see it
- I could see it, yeah.
- You could see where the
(bleep) was happening there.
- Yeah, exactly.
- He's like don't go down
there, it's crazy down there.
- It was too blurry
to know who was
the good dude and the
bad dude, you know.
(laughter)
- I like that, I just learned
something new today, adjacent.
Do you feel like
there's a difference
in your style of
comedy because you're a
West Coast based
stand up comedian.
- Definitely because, I
feel like I'm an L.A. dude.
because you know I
care about how I look.
There's a certain way we
talk, we enunciate, you know.
- I don't know, what is
that supposed to mean?
(laughter)
- You know L.A. guys
we talk this way.
- Okay.
- Properly, improper,
or something.
But you know, I don't
have like a souther drawl.
- I don't know if I'm going
to agree with that rule.
- I don't have that
East Coast, B, son.
I don't have a
drawl, I'm just like
that L.A. hire him immediately.
(laughter)
- I want to show
y'all some pictures
of James from back in the day.
When James first started
doing comedy, okay.
Let's look at the
hat, let's I mean uh.
- That's Chocolate
Sunday's First Impressions.
- [Kevin] First Impressions.
- That's when you
get three minutes
and then they're like, no more.
And I took it
straight to the face.
- Okay.
- Like three minutes--
- Let's just back up,
and let's just not, okay.
- Yeah, I mean pause.
- Yeah, yeah.
- I failed miserably.
- There you go, there you go.
- With my jokes.
They did not land.
- You didn't take
anything to the face.
- No, I didn't, I
took silence and
disappointment to the face.
- There you go, alright,
now we're clear.
- I'm about to send you off,
to enter the next level man.
This is big, one of
the biggest moments
in your life right now.
- Oh yeah.
- And I want you to
treat it as such.
- Yes sir.
- I don't want you hitting
the stage with those pants on.
- Oh no, this ain't
even the stage outfit.
- Oh this isn't
the stage outfit?
- I have a whole different
arsenal of apparel
that's going to be just
debuted with the material.
- I fell much better now.
- Watch me do it.
- Okay, okay.